[Musique]
et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
Michel Goya bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau officier des troupes de
Marie historiens militaire et enseignant
vous signez avec Jean Lopez l'ours c'est
le renard histoire immédiate de la
guerre en Ukraine qui vient de sortir
chez Perrin le bilan sous forme
d'entretien d'un longue entretien des 15
mois qui viennent de s'écouler en
Ukraine depuis l'invasion russe de
février 2022 on le disait à l'instant à
18e nuit en tout cas 18e salle d'attaque
sur Kiev en un mois cette nuit c'est la
politique russe de la terreur oui alors
vous savez il y a deux formes de guerre
ou de formes de combat soit on est sur
le terrain ces opérations de conquête on
peut les suivre sur la carte on voit des
petits drapeaux qui bougent soit on fait
on effectue des raids des frappes
l'intérieur de territoire et là c'est
beaucoup plus difficile à interpréter il
faut attendre en faisant cela on espère
obtenir quelque chose un effet émergent
un peu plus tard donc c'est toujours
très difficile à interpréter et les deux
une forme peuvent également se mêler
donc là ce qu'on constate c'est que il y
a deux parts d'autre d'ailleurs une
multiplication de ces raides de ces
frappes alors pourquoi faire c'est
côté russe il y a effectivement une
multiplication des attaques dont on voit
pas forcément quel est l'objectif il y a
eu la défense entière certainement
certainement c'est-à-dire que ces
attaques en réalité
s'effectue avec des beaucoup de drones
on utilise beaucoup de drones beaucoup
de missiles qui sont pas forcément
destinés à
sont pas faits pour ça c'est missiles
antérien des choses comme ça qui sont
utilisées donc il s'agit de faire
pression essentiellement on est plus
dans cette volonté qui avait par exemple
il y a quelques mois de détruire par
exemple tout le réseau électrique
ukrainien là il s'agit d'exercer une
pression forte de d'occuper un peu le
terrain aux espaces un peu médiatique
aussi de montrer que l'on fait quelque
chose et d'un point de vue strictement
militaire certainement d'attirer de
polariser une partie de la défense
anti-aérienne ukrainienne qui pour le
coup ne se trouve pas pas sur le front
et du côté ukrainien de Belgorod là on
voit ça depuis quelques jours sous
différentes formes d'ailleurs il y a
aussi des raids des frappes des raids
aériens par drone des des
raids de Thérèse on l'a vu du côté de
Belgrade de là aussi il s'agit à la fois
d'occuper un peu l'espace médiatique
peut-être de faire diversion sur sur
autre chose sur les événements de bac
mouth s'agit de faire une diversion
militaire aussi
en attirant également des forces russes
dans cette région plutôt qu'elles soient
sur le front est-ce que vous y voyez là
les prémices de la contre-attaque
ukrainienne qu'on attend qu'on attend
disons qu'on annonce depuis plusieurs
mois maintenant alors oui et non ou
alors en soi ces opérations peuvent se
suffire elles-mêmes c'est une manière de
faire quelque chose alors que sur le
terrain on est bloqué et en même temps
elles peuvent
s'inscrire en conjonction ou en
préparation de d'opération sur le
terrain d'opération de conquête alors
pas forcément du côté côté russe parce
qu'en là les Russes ont épuisés leur
capacité probablement de en tout cas de
mener des opérations offensives pour le
moment et mets du côté ukrainien oui ça
s'inscrit sans doute sans aucun doute
dans cette phase préparatoire avant le
jour J de cette grande opération
offensive que tout le monde attend et
qui est quasiment obligatoire et quel
est l'objectif militaire de cette
contre-offensive Ukraine n'a pris 15 de
la guerre
l'objectif stratégique craien c'est
toujours le même pour l'instant c'est
libérer le territoire
ukrainien de toutes les forces toutes
les troupes russes qui s'y trouvent les
territoire c'est l'objectif pour
l'instant et pour ça il y a pas 36
solutions il y a ils peuvent pas mener
une guerre comme ça de grignotage ou
même de raids de frappes comme ça c'est
pas ça qui qui va libérer le territoire
ukrainien il faut mener des opérations
offensives il faut casser le front il
faut percer il faut donner des grands
coups à l'armée russe et il faudra
d'ailleurs en donner plusieurs c'est pas
une opération si elle réussit offensive
si elle réussit qui
permettra d'attendre cet objectif il en
faudra certainement plusieurs mais ils
sont condamnés à ça et ils sont
condamnés aussi un petit peu à la
victoire donc il faut dans cette
opération
que ce soit dans le Nord ou probablement
dans la région de saporaja plantez le
drapeau quelque part sur un truc quelque
chose d'objectif important pour afficher
une victoire mais c'est pas évident du
tout et le résultat sera
l'échec ou la réussite va quand même
très largement conditionner la suite de
la guerre alors aussi et vous le
rappeler dans ce livre l'objectif
militaire des Ukrainiens n'a pas changé
depuis le début de cette invasion bien
sûr qu'ils ont subi en revanche côté
russe là c'est différent est-ce que vous
pouvez nous rappeler quel était
l'objectif de départ des Russes vous
avoir c'est l'occasion de faire ce petit
bilan et qu'elle est quel est-il
aujourd'hui alors les objectifs
stratégiques ils évoluent même
l'objectif crânien il a évolué au départ
c'était il suffisait de résister et à
l'invasion c'était déjà très bien
ramener les troupes russes sur la ligne
de départ du 24 février c'était ensuite
c'était aussi l'objectif sur et puis
après avec des moyens qui qui
s'accroisent le prise d'initiative des
courbes de puissance qui se croisent
plutôt au profit des Ukrainiens cet
objectif lui-même assez développé mais
il est pas dit que si cette offensive
crayon que l'on attend échoue ne sera
pas l'expérience sont pas obligés
peut-être de réduire les ambitions du
côté russe exemple Dombas qui avant
l'invasion russe en tout cas celle de
2022 était semi-perdu pour les
ukrainiens et là l'objectif affiché par
Zelinski c'est de reprendre aussi
l'intégralité du don masque complètement
maintenant du côté russe oui on était
parti sur des objectifs de maximaliste
incontestablement même s'ils étaient
relativement flou mais il s'agissait de
changer le régime d'occuper une grande
partie du territoire
mais là maintenant on est en situation
beaucoup plus comment dire beaucoup plus
simple beaucoup plus restrictive du côté
russe les Russes certaines façons mènent
au score ils ont conquis une partie du
territoire ukrainien si la guerre
s'arrêtait aujourd'hui pourrait Vladimir
Poutine pourrait proclamer victoire les
enfants c'est pas par exactement ce
qu'on voulait mais
on a libéré entre guillemets une partie
du territoire ukrainien qu'on a annexé
etc on a sauvé le Dombas donc on peut
s'en contenter et donc on est pour
l'instant dans une vision russe qui est
assez défensive attentiste qui joue
peut-être sur les mois à venir sur les
élections américaines qui va aussi
conditionner très certainement la suite
de la guerre et pour l'instant oui voilà
on est dans une posture plutôt d'attente
du côté russe pourquoi écrivez-vous je
vous cite que les Russes ont perdu deux
batailles mais pas la guerre que les
Ukrainiens ont gagné deux batailles mais
qu'ils n'ont pas gagné la guerre
oui ben on est dans une situation où
justement on a on est sur une position
d'équilibre des forces et c'est la
raison pour laquelle la guerre continue
c'est-à-dire que des deux côtés on a
encore un espoir de victoire on n'a pas
gagné sur le terrain mais on a l'espoir
de pouvoir le faire à terme donc on
continue et tant qu'il y a de l'espoir
en fait c'est la guerre c'est ça c'est
tant que vous avez le sentiment que les
efforts que vous faites encore un sens
peuvent être peuvent avoir un intérêt
vous continuez et dans les deux cas on
est dans cette dans cette posture donc
la guerre contre les batailles perdus
par les Russes ce sont
lesquels alors les grandes batailles
perdus par les Russes ce sont la
bataille de Kiev d'abord le tout début
de la guerre
russe ça très certainement sa dynamique
je pense que c'est pas complètement
remise de cette grande défaite puis
après il y a eu les les Russes ont
repris à nouveau initiative dans le
combat et puis les courbes l'ont aussi
sont croisées et les Ukrainiens repris
l'initiative et infligé deux défaites
spectaculaires importantes dans la
région province de kerkiff et dans la
tête de pont de sur la tête de pointe
Kerson ça c'est au mois de septembre
octobre
retournement à nouveau mobilisation
russe etc changement un peu de stratégie
à nouveau tentative du côté russe de
reprendre l'initiative dans le gambas
échec et maintenant le les cartes
changer de main certaines façons et
c'est autour des Ukrainiens de tenter
quelque chose
mais on le voit cette guerre elle est
scandée tous les deux trois mois vous
avez un changement de complètement de de
posture sans qu'on puisse à ce stade
vraiment définir qui a vraiment
l'avantage et qui a de fortes chances de
l'emporter 15 mois de guerre ça coûte
cher ça coûte cher en arsenal militaire
en en effort un scénario réaliste pour
les mois à venir vous le disiez tout à
l'heure les Russes sont épuisés on
imagine que l'usukrainiens aussi c'est
quoi c'est quelque chose qui pourrait
être alors on parlait cette
contre-offensive ukrainienne qu'on
attend
mais quoi oui la question c'est
fondamentalement est-ce que les
Ukrainiens vont réussir ou pas s'il
réussissent pas si échouent c'est le
défi est important les Russes sont
fortifiées c'est c'est point de vue
militaire c'est très compliqué c'est une
opération difficile à mener c'est pour
ça qu'ils prennent le temps quand même
de d'accumuler le moyen de faire de
travailler de se préparer les Ukrainiens
mais si échouent voilà il faudra
effectivement se poser des questions sur
un front qui va sera statique et là
c'est comment voilà comment on fait
comment on fait pour gagner la guerre
dans la situation où on ne peut pas
percer le front de l'autre
probablement que on assistera parce que
ça aussi c'est vous l'avez dit c'est
extrêmement coûteux ça demande beaucoup
de moyens
peut-être un épuisement des forces de
part et d'autre et une sorte de conflit
gelé c'est un scénario qui qui peut
durer ça ça peut durer très très
longtemps
Jean Lopez vous pose des questions très
intéressantes dans ce livre Michel Goya
toujours notamment celle bien sûr de
l'aide à portée par les alliés à
l'Ukraine est-ce que Kia fer aurait pu
tenir sans ses alliés et est-ce que la
réponse est si évidente que ça alors la
résistance
ukrainienne elle est bien d'abord
désukrainiens eux-mêmes et notamment de
la mobilisation humaine de toute cette
nation sont les nations qui font les
gars c'est pas les armées et donc vous
avez en Ukraine une nation qui est
complètement mobilisée dans cette guerre
ce qui est pas le cas complètement de la
Russie et c'est ça qui a fait au départ
qui a fait la différence maintenant sans
cette aide de son entraide
occidentale que ce soit de matériel
militaire mais aussi simplement
financière
c'est l'état ukrainien ne pourrait pas
fonctionner s'il ne recevez pas une aide
financière tout simplement les choses
ont été beaucoup plus compliquées
incontestablement et au moins en tout
cas les Ukrainiens n'ont pas n'aurait
pas été capable de reprendre
l'initiative
à partir de l'été de l'été dernier
est-ce que vous estimez un tournant quoi
après le l'été dernier autre point
intéressant de l'ouvrage vous dites que
c'est la première guerre ou l'image est
à ce point manipulée déformé fabriqué de
toute pièce oui alors c'est une guerre
où il y a énormément d'informations
c'est ce qui ça permet d'ailleurs
d'écrire ce livre c'est à dire que tout
un chacun peut maintenant reçoit ou peut
aller chercher une quantité incroyable
d'informations ça c'est un phénomène pas
complètement nouveau mais cette échelle
c'est peut-être assez inédit
le problème de cette information c'est
que elle est évidemment utilisée aussi
comme comme munition dans un combat de
communication d'un combat de manip
combat d'influence c'est ça c'est
évidemment très important l'opinion
publique
occidental américaine particulier mais
occidental c'est un élément du champ de
bataille si d'un seul coup on a décidé
de ne plus soutenir l'Ukraine l'Ukraine
serait un très mauvaise posture donc du
coup nous devons une cible
contestablement de la part de toute
cette politique d'influence russe mais
aussi de l'influence ukrainienne bien
sûr donc il y a un jeu nous sommes un
enjeu de cette guerre vous êtes bien
placé pour le savoir Michel Goya parce
que vous êtes consultant pour une chaîne
d'information en continu ici en France
vous le militaire BFMTV pour ne pas la
nommer qu'il faille un consultant ça dit
quoi de cette guerre et de notre rapport
médiatique à cette guerre on parlait de
l'abondance d'information mais
l'information c'est c'est du bruit si on
n'arrive pas à l'interpréter
essentiellement donc d'où
l'importance d'avoir des gens qui sont
qui soient capables justement
d'interpréter cette information d'en
faire quelque chose de compréhensible
pendant toute la crise de covid vous
avez invité
vous avez invité des médecins des
spécialistes de la question pour rendre
les choses intelligibles là c'est on est
sur quelque chose d'assez inédit il faut
bien il faut bien l'avouer sur l'appel à
des experts militaires quoi c'est encore
les encore les meilleurs experts de de
la chose militaire de notre propre
métier effectivement Emmanuel Macron
en un mot politique majeur en
envahissant l'Ukraine de d'accord avec
lui oui bien sûr c'est c'est la raison
pour laquelle d'ailleurs beaucoup de
gens dans moi douter de même
ce serait tellement contre-productif un
congrès oui exactement
Vladimir Poutine savait enfin si
rétrospectivement ce qui allait se
passer il est probable qu'il n'aurait
pas lancé cette cette invasion il avait
déjà obtenu un certain nombre de choses
par la simple pression par la par la
peur par l'intimidation la mobilisation
des forces il pouvait obtenir des choses
là en déclenchant cette invasion il a
bon là ça a déjà été évoqué de
l'entreprise mais il a obtenu bien
souvent en fait l'effet inverse qu'il
souhaitait obtenir la guerre l'ours
c'est le renard je vous laisse deviner
qui est l'ours qui est le renard Michel
Goya avec Jean Lopez livre passionnant
sur l'histoire immédiate de cette guerre
en Ukraine merci infiniment d'être venu
ce matin nous en parler